hello everybody I hope you're good I
didn't expect to see myself bringing you
an update on Saturday but things
escalated pretty quickly yesterday and
Bitcoin went to the week
the guys in the trading course know more
about this but weeks are essentially
liquidity imbalances in the chart and
um the minimum Target is the 50 of the
week and the second target the final
Target is the 100 of the week
I'm Bitcoin filled yesterday the week
exactly to the door that you can see now
it's ringing over here because it's the
weekend there is no much liquidity
across the chart you guys not all the
financial districts are closed the
stocks Forex
institutions are not trading they have
the day off they're with their families
so there is not much liquidity if we go
to the Daily time frame let me show you
because I think Bitcoin is at a very
critical point
it's right now
playing around the daily 50 EMA what
does this mean
he needs to hold it
it needs to hold the CMA because if it
doesn't hold
it's gonna go lower
simple as that
so
this is what I'm going to be paying
attention over the weekend to see if it
can hold this level
because if not we'll go lower
I think that this is the most
interesting thing in the daily time
frame at the moment and is the daily 50
EMA so you can see how Bitcoin is right
now slightly above it but let's see how
it's tomorrow and on Monday morning
because this might
tell us a lot about the next move now if
you go back to the four hour time frame
there is something that I'm actually
liking here well first is that it has
been felt fully so that's one less thing
to worry about and now something I'm
liking
are all these weeks over here because
it's telling me that so far even want
Bitcoin to go lower
so the question is is the market maker
building his locks in this Zone
maybe to recover part of this large red
candle
maybe the only concern that I have is
that at the moment there are a lot of
short positions open okay that could
trigger a sword squeeze but if you think
about those traders that are currently
thinking about opening a long position
or have already opened the long position
in this area
take a pro is set their stop losses in
this area
okay
below all these weeks so this is
basically telling me that I can't
discardivia of Bitcoin doing something
like this
this is my quick analysis about Bitcoin
board remember that
Bitcoin is usually quite boring at the
weekend so we might see more of a range
here still okay and tomorrow it's Sunday
so I will post the useful Sunday update
on Twitter I'm also thinking about
uploading it to YouTube so you have it
in both formats in text and in video and
in the Sunday update I'll go more in
depth and I'll try to find more
confidence to support an analysis maybe
I changed my idea and I don't draw this
anymore but this is just my quick quick
view let's go now to high blow Capital
to see all those liquidations I want to
see how they hit them and let's see
where the liquidity is right now okay so
remember this is a very brief idea okay
maybe a drop towards 27 000 maybe a bit
lower even because you know they like to
play with round number so maybe they
could scare us and go to 27 900 or so
for a potential bounce but again let's
go to the high block and let's see what
he's doing
ah this is amazing to see 27 400
liquidation look at that yellow bar
the next one was a 27 100 also hit and
now we can see that there is still some
liquidity at 27
000 and 26
900. the question is
are they gonna come lower to come back
up or are they gonna abandon this Zone
and go to the next one that's around 25
600 25 300 that's the high time frame
previous resistance
that could be this is a support soon
we're gonna go back to the Bitcoin chart
in a minute so I can show you the level
again
but this is quite interesting 27 000 26
900 a lot of liquidations remember I was
telling you and it was that Bitcoin
right now might be ranging over here
okay and setting this as the new Range
so there might be a lot of logs getting
open soon and the rest stop losses would
be below this zone so they would match
with the liquidations that means that
even if there are no liquidations and
there is stop losses there is going to
be a lot of liquidity added to this zone
so twenty seven thousand twenty six
thousand hundred is definitely an
interesting Zone that might get test
soon
back to Bitcoin now I think everything
is pretty much said there must be a
bounce from here if this one holds but I
even like that they are more of a
potential stockhold first before a
bounce okay but if this Zone doesn't
hold which is the daily 50 EMA okay then
we're gonna go lower to the direction
and the next zone is the 25
000 so let me show you this this one was
talking earlier in high block
I would say around
this levels well this is more accurate
to be honest 25
200. look at this there was a seller
from here then price went back to this
level another sell-off
is it possible that between comes back
to this Elm to test it as support yes
why not it hasn't done it yet so he
might do it
so that's everything I wanted to say
guys you know I like to keep you updated
so I felt the need to plot this video
and today well this evening I'm gonna
try to post a threat on Twitter about
the two gr deals chart because something
is going on there okay so guys have a
very nice weekend I'll see you tomorrow
probably Again on YouTube with the
Sunday update it'll be on Twitter too
and see you soon